much traveling going on around for many
of us so hey when it starts up and
running I'll be keen to get back on with
it so that takes us now onto our agenda
and the next page you'll see our agenda
that we're going to cover today I'm not
going to read through all of those
because as we come across it I will then
touch upon it so let's move straight on
to our next page and so I thought we'd
start off with a poll because I'd like
to gauge how people feel about salary
negotiation so our first poll of today
is how do you feel about negotiating
your salary do you feel confident are
you okay with it are you unsure how to
negotiate not confident or apprehensive
or it's a taboo topic okay so how do you
feel about salary negotiation right so I
am going to launch the poll now and
hopefully you should also see that poll
I'm going to give you all about a minute
to enter your thoughts so here's goes
okay great
I can see some of you started entering
there's a lot more if you still cast
your votes how do you feel okay yeah
this keeps changing there was a lot of
confidence in the beginning but it's now
changing okay we're not quite there 100%
going to give you about 30 more seconds
to go okay any more coming how do you
feel
okay almost there couple more seconds
right
okay start it anymore
come on about two percent more can we
get it up
okay so our minutes up how do you feel
about negotiating your salary so 13% of
you thought you felt confident the
majority of you 47% are unsure how to
negotiate and 33% said they don't feel
confident I present a prehensile and
interesting in our 77% sorry of you say
it's attribute topic and I know in some
cultures and just some countries it is
very much a taboo topic interesting to
see how many of you have voted for
unsure how to negotiate and that you're
not confident hopefully by the time we
get to the end of this webinar you'll be
feeling much more confident in your
skills and your ability to negotiate
okay thanks very much everyone for
participating in that poll so now we can
move on to our next topic
okay so now let's look at taking the
fear out of salary negotiations so we're
going to actually be looking at some
more statistics around people's attitude
to salary negotiation so according to a
survey by a recruitment firm Robert Hart
around 39 percent of workers tried to
negotiate a higher salary during their
last job offer 46 percent of men written
negotiated salary compared to 34 percent
of women so if you Liat clearly there's
an indication that men are more likely
to negotiate their salary than women and
workers age 18 to 34 were forty-five
percent more likely to negotiate their
salary than those aged 35 to 54 which
were 40 percent likely to negotiate
their salaries and those aged at 55 or
older was 30 percent likely to negotiate
their salary when asked how comfortable
they were talking with their employer
about money 54 percent of the survey
respondents said that they would feel
more comfortable negotiating a higher
salary of a new employer than asking for
a raise in their current job so thinking
about given all the nervousness that we
have when it comes to salary negotiation
does it actually pay to negotiate well a
study by recruitment company job white
founder 84
percent of those who did negotiate their
salaries ended up with receiving higher
salaries so short answer is yeah
it pays to negotiate okay so let's move
on to the next slide and again still
thinking around the topic of taking the
fear out of negotiation instead we're
gonna just sort of talk through a little
bit about mindset around a negotiation
so some of the things that hold us back
so given the amount of importance we
attach to our salary why are people so
reluctant to negotiate for what they
really want well quite often people
start their job search with a scarcity
mindset our minds tend to envision a
hundred percent of people applying for a
small amount of positions so when we get
through the interview process and are
finally presented with the job offer we
feel so relieved to be chosen but we
dare not rock the boat the number one
factor holding people back from
negotiating is fear fear the company
will retract the job offer basically
unless you're aggressive or
unprofessional
this is highly unlikely to happen
remember you and the employer will have
put a lot of time and energy through
going through the interview process the
company will also have invested a lot of
resources and therefore they are not
going to want to throw all of our effort
way simply because you counter-offered
what's the worst case scenario well they
may say our offer is firm best case your
counter is accepted however the most
likely outcome is that you and the
employer will work together and end up
somewhere in between their offer and
your counteroffer another factor is the
lack of skills people often avoid
negotiating because they feel that they
lack skills to properly negotiate their
salary and they find the negotiation
process stressful and unpleasant
negotiation is top work and that is why
preparation is key self doubt about our
value this is a genuine concern for a
lot of people
how can you negotiate your salary when
you're not really sure what you're worth
or what your value is this is especially
true for those of you who are
transitioning to a different career you
may know what you're worth in your
industry or region but how do you know
what you're worth
to the company you may think the company
knows your value best but often
companies will offer you an amount with
the expectation that you are likely to
come back with a counteroffer
if you simply accept the offer then you
will never really know how much you they
think you're truly worth some people
think I don't want to come across as
greedy well if you counteroffer they
might think that but also equally you
may find out that their initial offer
wasn't actually their best offer
and that they actually let some headroom
in case you counteroffer it businesses
are all about maximizing value by
putting in a counteroffer
you are also demonstrating your ability
to maximize your value other things that
people think about and worried about
what holds them back we think the
employer have the upper hand so
basically we think the employer holds oh
they'll cut all the cars of their chests
and we have no choice well that's a
salary I signed up for is what we tell
ourselves it's only a small company
culturally it's not something we do and
a really really common one is people
often think I'll get my foot in the door
and then I'll ask for a raise on the
surface this may sound good
you won't appear greedy and you don't
need to haggle about what you're worth
so everybody's happy right problem is
once you get inside a company there's
often a ceiling on the amount of a raise
you can get at any given time therefore
the 10% uplift you were hoping to
negotiate for will not mask materialize
because company policy that takes that
you can only get a 6% raise per annum
your mindset around salary negotiation
is 95% psychological discomfort around
the negotiation process is a natural
feeling salary negotiation isn't
something you do regularly the reality
is that most employees expect some
degree or pushback when it comes to
salary negotiation for new hires it's
all about adopting the right approach to
negotiation you don't want to come
across as a dora aragon or Demand in
moving on to our next slide let's have a
little talk through why is salary
negotiation important well first of all
it's important to get the right mindset
when
it comes to negotiating your salary and
here's why in actual fact when you think
it through there is no sound side to
asking what's the worst thing that can
happen if you negotiate your salary well
you are simply asking for more money
based on what you believe your value is
provided you are being professional like
I said before are not being arrogant or
demanding your request will either be
accepted or rejected if is accepted
right you get more money if it's
rejected well you still have the salary
initially offered to you on the table
and if you're negotiating from a
position where you're already in a job
then you will still receive your
existing salary ultimately the outcome
will either be positive or it will
remain neutral there is no downside
what's another factor to consider well
it could affect your future salary the
way how your future pay is kill not
calculated is often based off the back
of your starting salary so even if you
change roles within the organization the
company may use your existing salary as
the baseline for determining your new
salary if you start on a higher amount
that gives you room to negotiate for
even more money once you're inside the
company confidence and integrity when
you understand your value you can
another shape much more confidently when
you negotiate it also demonstrates an
employer that you are willing to put
time and effort into conducting proper
research being upfront about your
expectation shows that you are being
transparent and operating with integrity
employer incentives what do I mean by
that employers are not motivated to give
you more money upfront and they will not
reveal what the previous person doing
the role earned so the chances are they
are expecting you to come back with a
counteroffer on the basis that you've
done your homework
for these reasons many employers offer a
salary slightly below the going rate if
you accept that initial figures
straightaway you will be operating at a
loss since they were prepared to pay you
more if you counter offered try not to
think of salary negotiation as a
conflict it's an important conversation
between two parties who want to come to
an agreement so that both parties get
what they want
you get paid what you're worth and in
return they get your full focus and
attention
moving on to our next slide I've got
another poll for you and so I'm
interested as part of your research when
you're job searching which salary sites
do you use as part of your salary
research for jobs is it Glassdoor
because I know many of you know about
Glassdoor it's at Glassdoor plus another
site
do you use monetary salary sites to help
you with your research or do you not do
any salary research at all so this is
your next poll question and I am about
to launch this poll so I'm going to
where's my next there's my next poem
goes back on hold on one moment
everybody summaries and I'm not seeing
here it is okay right
I'm going to launch the second poll here
it goes so I'm gonna give you again
about a minute to tell me which salary
sites do you use as part of your salary
research yeah and are interesting very
mixed okay Wow
yeah we're getting a real sense of
variety here what people do okay we're
almost there at 90 percent these polls
are totally 100% anonymous guys so
nobody's going to know what you voted or
how you voted okay so hopefully that
will give you confidence to put your
your vote in so at 90 percent can we get
it up to 100% be great if we could okay
you have got 10 more seconds so 10 will
set 95 percent fantastic okay
five more seconds then I'm gonna end the
poll ok polls ended so what have we got
we have got 37% of you use Glassdoor so
that's the majority and I hear a lot of
students talking about Glassdoor
so I'm not surprised that that resolved
16% of you use glass door and one other
salary survey
actually 32% of you which is interesting
used multiple salary sites which is
great glad to hear that a lot of you are
comparing and 21% don't do any salary
research at all so hopefully by the end
of this webinar you those of you who
don't do any salary research at all will
see the importance of actually doing
salary research which is quite critical
and crucial to understanding your value
so thank you all very much for
participating in that poll and so we can
now move on to our next item or our next
slide so moving on again we are just
finishing off on taking your feet no
taking the fear so now we're going to
move on to our next topic which is
knowing your financial worth okay so
this is crucial when it comes to
negotiating and understanding your
financial well first point that I want
you to understand is that there is a
difference between your worth and your
value okay so your worth is the amount
of money you expect to receive and this
it will be based on your education level
it's been be based on your level of
experience geographical location as well
as how you present yourself before
during and after the interview your
value is about the strength and the
skills care you will bring to the
position and the organization from the
organization's perspective the worth of
the position will be the salary range
for the job the value however is the
organization's need of that position so
how critical is that position to the
organization moving on to our next slide
again we're going to go into a phase
where we look at some of the caps some
of the salary tools so the idea is an
excellent candidate for a job will be
able to match their Worth and value to
those of the job and organization and in
order to do that you need to of course
do some thorough research and to help
you and to be able to understand Worth
and value there are a number of sites
that collects salary information based
on job title
and some of you know know some of them
Glassdoor very common salary.com
monster.com indeed payscale.com
comparable and there are others which I
haven't mentioned but there are a number
of sites that you can use and they
contain a salary calculation tools that
can assist you and working out what
you're worth some of these sites also
have the salary ranges the company that
you might be interviewing now so do take
your time in deciding which site works
best for you and for your purposes and
may actually have the information that
you're looking for on the specific
company that you're interviewing at so
let's take a look closer at some of
these salary tools and move on to the
next slide where you'll be able to see
an example so they were lucky so there
are a number of different scenario Asian
tools each to present a range of
information in different formats they
give different levels of information
some of the online tools are based on
real people real life data and the first
one that you will see is the salary tool
for Glassdoor so for those of you who
use Glassdoor to do your salary research
will be very familiar with this
screenshot a blaster is a site where
people anonymously report their salaries
I use data scientists as the job search
title for this and I used London and as
a starting point I'm based in London so
I just thought it's the initial one I'll
use London
so I've tailored the sorts the search to
basically find out how much data
scientists earn in London as you can see
the salary ranges from 35 K to 75 K with
an average pay of fifty thousand eight
hundred and forty three pounds per year
okay so that's an example of what you
stay for you went to the glass door
moving on to the next page this is a
sample of monster coms salary calculator
tool and I'm not sure how many of you
use it but however monster.com provides
you with additional information so what
you will see here is obviously it gives
you the salary range which most and all
of them will give you but in addition to
that you will notice that it also
highlights which skills could increase
your value so it mentions machine
learning and time series analysis
and you'll see that on the bottom
left-hand corner so there's a there's a
little box which tells you about you
know how to boost your value the other
data I should have mentioned is you'll
see that they even though it's still
data scientists is that I've changed the
location so I'll change the location to
Los Angeles California just thought it
would be good to see the contrast and
you will also notice that it gives an
indication of the salary for other jobs
in the data science field so if you're
looking for something closely connected
to data scientists and you're thinking
well what else could I do which is
affiliated you'll see in the middle box
there's a box title salary for related
jobs which can take you through to
information on those particular jobs
data engineer etc let's move to our next
slide and have a look at salary comm
salary tools so what you see here is a
screenshot from salary comms tool this
tool allows you to do a more granular
search by including details such as your
education years of experience who will
be your direct report it also shows
other payments you may get such as
bonuses so it gives you a complete
package or a picture of the complete
package you might receive and what's
also helpful about salary comm is this
is an example of one of the tools that
you can use to search by company so if
you look on the left hand side and
you've got the know your Worth and part
or area where you can sort of type in
the job title you're searching under but
further below that you'll see the sort
of green button and below that you'll
see it's got search tools that you can
look for so if you look for skills you
can look for company and that can
probably be very useful and helpful to
some of you until you're identifying at
a particularly well-known company and
you want to find out a bit more
specifically about what type of package
that company offers so let's move on to
the next slide and interestingly enough
this again is from salary comm and they
offer a personalized salary report
report which are tailored and takes into
account your personalized substance
circumstances it highlights factors
specific to you that are likely to
increase your
under an area title key strengths you do
have to pay for this service and it
costs between $25 and $75 so it could
get quite expensive fee for you are
thinking of getting ripple for a couple
of companies you might be interviewing
at why might you get one well you are
provided with an 18 page report and it
includes things like preparing for a
raise worksheet and it gives you two
pages covering negotiating negotiation
dialogue and scenarios so it basically
gives you ideas how to respond at the
negotiation stage some people may feel
that it's worth getting this if they've
landed an interview of their ideal
company and really want that additional
support at the negotiation stage turning
to our next slide this is the last
salary tool that we look at like I say
there are a lot out there but I've just
chosen these ones and this is indeed
salary tool and again you'll see the job
title is data scientists lightly other
tools that gives you the salary range
however it also breaks the salary range
down based on years of experience it
highlights the common benefits you get
River roll so that's quite interesting
to understand what if the whole package
look like then it also shows you
interestingly enough who are the top
paying companies in that territory for
data science and then it gives you a
list of the highest paying cities in
that territory which could be very good
if you are strategically and targeting
which area you'd like to work in and
you're able to then sort of see and do a
comparison between which different area
what the pay that different areas are
likely to give you for the same role so
now we're going to turn to our next
slide okay and so once you properly
research the salary range for the role
you're interested in use it to determine
a positions where whichever salary tool
you choose to use remember your work
needs to take into account your
qualification and experience so it's not
just based on the job title you need to
take into account your location or where
the job is located this could have the
biggest effect on your salary
expectations the industry
so salary ranges vary widely from
industry to industry so depending on
which industry you're in you may find a
significant difference if you move to a
data science role for example another
industry the company size though
generally larger sizes companies tend to
pay better than smaller sized companies
and again better than early-stage
startups you've also need to take into
account the job title the grade and your
responsibilities these will all play
into your salary expertise again are you
in a high demand field or will you be
going into a highly specialized area
this is likely to put you in a position
where you may be able to negotiate
beyond the average salary pay for the
role so let's move on to the next
question again we're still all know your
financial worth so some question that
you may ask which causes deeper thinking
in terms of around value think so like I
said before to help you determine the
value of the position think about things
like why is the position vacant so has
the role been vacant for a long time are
they struggling to fill it and what
makes you unique compared to other
candidates is the company looking for a
unique skillset different companies are
looking for different skills some
companies will genuinely view you more
valuable than others the other thing to
bear in mind is how well do you fit with
the company culture these all have a
bearing and impact on value having this
information will help you prepare for
your interview and also for the question
that everyone gets nervous about what
salary package are you looking for this
is one of the questions that I know a
lot of people get nervous around when an
employer or a recruiter asked them this
question this question can be based and
it can be asked of you at any stage of
the interview process so I'm asked it
some people ask it before the interview
stage so I'm wait until they decide to
make you an offer some may ask it at
stage 2 or stage 3 the first thing I
recommend is if you're asked this
question hold on to this information for
as long as possible and definitely
resist answering this directly during
the first stage interview here's why at
the initial interview stage
will not have a chance had a chance to
showcase your skills and abilities you
will also not have had a chance to
really understand what your
responsibilities will be and what their
expectations are or what type of
compensation package they are offering
you really want to be revealing this
information when things are stacked in
your favor when is that likely to be
well that is likely to be at the end of
the process when they're willing to make
you an offer and you've clearly won them
over some companies will push you to
give them a number if you find yourself
in that situations here's one one of the
things that you can say based on market
research and what I know about your
company the range that I'm thinking of
is X amount however I'd really like to
continue discussions around the role so
that we can both see how I might be a
value to your team once that's clear
then we can discuss the compensation
package in more detail if that works for
you when you say something like that
you'll see you haven't actually
committed to a number but you've given
them an idea of what you're thinking
around even if that might be initial
starting point so you don't want to
commit to a figure too early in the
process once you demonstrate the value
you can bring to the combined company
they will be more likely to consider
your ideal number so let's move on to
the next slide so we're going to be
covering another topic now impact of
Copa 19 on jobs and before we do that I
just want to spend a minute or two just
getting you to share your thoughts so
for those of you who have been job
hunting recently what is your experience
of jump hunting since the LA time so if
you could just type in the chat box I'd
be grateful what's your experience or
job hunting since the lockdown and I
know it's going to be very varied
because I know some people have actually
been interviewing I've come across
students have been interviewing and some
people has decided to make a decision
that they're not going to be searching
at the moment that they're actually
going to be investing their time in
learning and development so they
utilizing this time and isolation
to upskill themselves better what are
your thoughts yeah
great so my colleague mirrors in the
chat room to establish your thoughts
what are people thinking yep markets
market has changed there are there are
jobs out there yeah
so anybody share your thoughts are
people thinking there are jobs people
are yep some of you are on hold 100%
totally understand that it's not much
changes in certain areas leave there
okay so it's interesting yeah some
people have decided to 100% know how
they're gonna wait anyone else was gonna
share okay not sure whether now's the
right time to apply hiring freezes yeah
yep there are hiring freezes on focusing
on learning now instead of job hunting
interesting people are noticing lot less
offers than it was before the lot done
yeah I can agree with that
okay open to job offers fantastic son
has completed the nanodegree and they're
open yeah hopefully now as things are
moving along and the lockdown is being
slowly opened out more in certain
countries people will start to see more
changes so here in the UK we're slowly
sort of coming out of lockdown in stages
and people are able to meet up a bit
more and businesses more importantly are
starting to open up so hopefully as a
result of that this will push through to
the recruitment market and people will
start to see hiring freezes lifted but
we're going to talk a bit more about
that now so let's just now move on to
our next slide
okay okay so covert 19 potential impact
on jobs so as most of you know it has
definitely impacted the way employers
conduct their business and also is
impacting how they plan for the future
some employers have ramped up their
technology hiring others have put a
freeze on the hiring of non-essential
roles and some have resented
unfortunately initial offers so I know
people who've had internships pulled
unfortunately in others who have had job
offers also rescinded and moving on to
our next slide we are going to take a
look at some statistics to help us get a
better understanding of what's really
going on in the job market from a tech
perspective and now these statistics
from the hiring company dice now many of
you will know if dice and probably use
their job search board to search for
jobs and they actually produced a report
on the early impact of those at 19 on
hiring the tech industry and they found
the top employers of q1 2020 primarily
primarily consisted of tech giants
consulting agencies and government
contractors between my heart for example
Amazon increased its tech job posting by
a hundred and ten percent they were
looking to hire software developers and
network engineers as the impact of
covert 19 led many consumers to turn to
Amazon as alternative to go into the
grocery store or hardware stores Walmart
also increased its job postings in March
by 64% software developers and project
manager roles topped the lot of roles
the retailer was looking to film and
again you will see examples of other
well-known employers who sort of again
increase their hiring potential drew in
that period so system systems is down
there
you've got Sony you've got NBC so all of
these are showing statistics of job
hiring in the tech sector so moving on
to our next page which has some more
statistics however this again again it's
from DICE this is shown the change in
tech job postings from Feb to march 2020
and you will notice that there's a
significant
increase in cybersecurity roles and this
was due to the number of pandemic theme
phishing and cyber attacks which then
led businesses to increase their
cybersecurity roles and so basically you
know a lot of businesses started to face
attacks with people sort of with us
fishing and cyber where became really a
hot theme for businesses and so you will
notice here that there has been a
significant increase in their cyber
security engineering job posters in
March businesses such as Wells Fargo
Northrop Grumman and BAE Systems top the
list of employers looking to hire the
most cyber security engineers job
postings for system engineers also rose
by 11 percent between further March
this suggests that companies are
increasing their focus on maintaining
their network and infrastructure in
these circumstances
so I act Raytheon and Northrop Grumman
were all looking to hire system
engineers at the highest volume in March
now let's also look at decline in job
posting so interestingly you will see
that there's been a decline in job
posting for software developers that was
bound 8 percent of front-end developers
was down 25% between further March this
suggest that many employers may be d
prioritizing new projects to focus on
core project offerings and
infrastructure maintenance so moving on
to the next slide and this is the last
set of Justices distict we will look at
and this slide relates to tech skill
demands between Feb and March 20 20 s so
with a revised of Kovan 19 it appears
that employees have taken a great
interest in skills that contribute to
the maintenance and shifting of
companies technology infrastructure the
requirement for people with dev ops
skills grew by nine percent between 7
March C++ grew by 7% on quality
assurance grew by 6% Python grew by 4%
one suggestion for this is that
employers are not only looking for
technologies who can handle immense
amounts of legacy code written in Python
but technologists who can also build new
apps and services that can help
companies adjust to a post covert 19
world it's worth noting which skills
fell over that period
web-development fell by 25% Ruby which
you can't see in the chart
actually fell by 30% what's behind this
decrease dye suggest it's down to
companies being forced to take a
reaction response on the curve at 19
with priority and focus centered around
setting employees up to work remotely
rather than updating their website
however as we move to a different phase
of covert 19 employees unlikely to take
another look at their long-term webbing
infrastructure project another thing to
account for going forward is the
potential change the salary offers as
businesses tried to recover from the
financial impact to covert 19 and hiring
freezes are removed it is quite likely
that the salary for future jobs unlikely
to come under closer scrutiny and you
may well find that they're coming in at
a lower range than they would have pre
cove at 19 interestingly also to take
today on the next slide so hopefully you
can all see that final poll I'm gonna
get ready to launch it did you negotiate
your salary at the job offer stage or
ask for a pay rise at your previous
performance review so that's going to be
your Oh
so yes you might have answer yes
negotiating my salary at job offer
station and ask for a pay right during
my last performance review yet you may
have negotiated your salary at the job
offer stage oh yes she negotiated for a
pay rise at your last work performance
review or maybe no you didn't negotiate
for a pay rise either at your last job
offer or at your last performance review
so I am about to launch this poll so
buddy here goes it's launching this poll
so interesting to understand did you
negotiate your salary
okay gonna give you guys a minute and
see how you get on okay interesting how
confident were you feeling at your last
bubble huh
oh the roots coming in fantastic keep
them coming in we're 60% great 40% more
to come in and keep going guys a little
interesting the dynamics are changing
remember this is a hundred percent
anonymous people won't know how you
voted yeah fantastic rate are 88 percent
come on come on you can do it a hundred
be great if we can get 100 percent it's
really interesting to understand did you
negotiate your salary up the drop off
the stage okay
got about I'm gonna give you all number
five seconds we're at 88% can we at
least get it up to 90 okay five more
seconds and then I am going to call
anybody else okay
that's it I'm going to close the poll
okay the results are in so what happened
55% of you said no you didn't negotiate
at all either at the initial job offer
stage or your last performance play
review how many so again interestingly
and then it splits up to 18% for the
rest so 18 percent of you did negotiate
your salary at the job off the stage and
answer a pay rise during your last work
performance good on you
those me who did 18 percent of you says
yes you negotiated at your last job
offer and 18 percent of you said yes you
negotiated a pay rise at your last pay
performance review so thanks so much
guys for sharing that information with
us that's really helpful to know and
understand where you're out on this so
we are now going to move on to our next
slide and topic so this is going to be
all about creating your negotiation
strategy okay and some of you may have
to go at doing your own type of strategy
and putting one in place but what I want
to do now is basically I want you all to
imagine at this scenario so imagine
you're at home and you receive a call
from the HR manager a recruiter for a
job you've been interviewing for they've
got some feedback for you from your
final stage interview the company would
like to make you an offer at this point
please know make sure you grab a pen and
paper to capture the conversation resist
the temptation to rush into the detail
of the offer first ask for feedback on
your interview it's important to
understand what the company liked about
you or what skills or quality stood out
for them you want to capture this
because the tendency is that when you're
on the phone there's a lot of stuff that
is said either by the HR manager by a
recruiter which they're not real
necessarily willing to commit to emails
though emails tend to be a lot more Vega
so make sure you catch your important
points that have said on the telephone
that way if you need to follow up on a
point that's been mentioned you've got
it written down and you can follow it up
at a later stage remember if you're at
this stage it means that you showcase
your skills well and the organization or
confident are convinced that you are the
right person for the job
so therefore you should start off on a
confident footing now once you've
captured all that feedback about how you
performed at the interview it's now time
for you to go in and get some more
details if while they're talking to you
the figure comes out and the offer
appears to come on on the low side make
sure you listen to their full
explanation of what the salary package
entails even if you're disappointed with
the initial offer maintain a positive
attitude let them know you're really
liked the company and you'd really like
to work for them but the money offer
doesn't quite work for you you're sure
they'll be able to come up with a salary
package that works for both parties do
not feel pressured to make a decision on
the spot ask for more time to think
about him and here's why if the offer is
75 K and you immediately asked if they
can do 80 K you've just told them what
it will take to get you on board without
taking time to reflect on what you've
been offered if we reflect on what you
said after the conversation and think
I should ask for a slightly higher
figure you've already closed the window
of opportunity and now you have to
negotiate within that range
chances are the company will come back
to you with a figure in between so say
around 78 K asking for more time allows
you also to followup with companies you
may be interviewing with at the same
time to gauge whether or not they can
expedite the interview process in the
hope that you may get another offer to
compare and compete with against your
initial offer another point that you
really need to consider it's mind your
words during the conversation so if you
decide you're going to make a
counteroffer on the core and you state
your number followed by a comment along
the lines of I totally understand if you
can't do this
you totally undercut the value for what
you're asking for don't give away
permission for them to turn you down be
clear and but be affirmative in your
language think about communicating
something along the lines or given the
market range for positions similar to
this one I'm requesting a 10% Korean
increase or whatever the increase you're
looking for on my offer looking forward
to talking with you more about this and
what would be reasonable market rate for
my value to the company you then might
want to add you're looking forward to
working together you want to keep the
relationship pleasant and moving forward
and you want to make sure that they
understand that you really are keen and
want to work with them moving on to the
next slide
assuming you've asked them and you told
them you want to think it over
and you've got thinking over time what
do you do next well you're going to use
that time to sit down and reflect on
whether the salary package as a whole
meet your expectation that it truly
reflect the responsibilities and
bilities needed to do the job you may
even want to come up with some sort of
scoring sheet where you put down the
actual salary amount plus the benefit so
the non sort of cash elements of the
package that are important to you and
rate them give them a rating and think
about which ones that you might want to
include as part of your negotiation
tactics so for example you may find out
as part of the process that there will
only be two of you in the team and that
you will be expected to deputize for
your bot when he or she is away this may
in
cause you to reflect on how much it is
you now really want for the job or what
your expectations are remind yourself of
what your were so if you done your
homework thoroughly before the interview
you will have a button and figure in
mind so this bottom M figure is the
absolute lowest amount salary you are
willing to accept and you will also have
an ideal figure so that's going to be
your topper man and then there will be a
figure in between which you are
comfortable with accepting then keep in
mind the work and value of the position
to the organization and make sure you
negotiate within that salary range so
I'm moving on to the next slide when
you're preparing your response decide
whether you want to respond by email or
talk it over the through talk it through
over the phone some of you will feel
more comfortable responding and
communicating by email some of you will
feel totally comfortable speaking over
the phones totally up to you remember
you're negotiating for your compensation
package as a whole so pay attention to
other elements that make up your
compensation package these also affect
your standard of living and quality of
life
how much paid time off will you get
what's the bonus structure are they
offering health insurance will they be
investing in your career progression so
paying for you to go on courses will
there be growth potential these are all
important points to consider decide what
you value and let that help you guide
your negotiation strategy maybe you can
negotiate some additional vacation leave
instead of the base salary increase if
you're going to negotiate over the phone
create a script and practice practice
practice let's move on to our next slide
so I just want to cover a couple of do's
and don'ts to keep in mind when you're
negotiating so one of the first points
that I've mentioned here is take the
emotion out of it so what do I mean by
that well the fact that you've got a
number of financial commitments has
nothing and is of no interest to do with
the company that are interested in that
okay this is purely a business
conversation if you're going to knead a
dough shape make sure you do it from a
professional values perspective so build
your cases to what value that you bring
to the company how are you going to
benefit and what's the value add the
additional sort of skill
that you're bringing and that they will
benefit from base it around that and
build your case around that what's your
time you're not in a conflict situation
you're having an important conversation
that needs to be managed you don't want
to come across as aggressive take deep
breaths if you need to be flexible
organizations are often tied up by
policies and procedures so whilst they
may not be able to budge on the salary
they may be willing to move on to other
elements of the compensation package
which is why I suggested to you to have
that scoring table where you decide to
prioritize which are the other elements
of the package apart from the salary is
important to you if you bang on and on
about the just the salary figure it can
connect get quite annoying to the
company that and make you not like all
you're interested in is the money now if
a factor to make sure you cover all your
points of concern at one time so don't
go out with two points then see if you
get them then go back with a couple more
points see if you can get that as well
that approach will only irritate the
employer it'll also make you look
incompetent and as if you're not sure
what you really really want so when
you're going out if you've got points of
concern make sure you document them and
you put them all in one email or one
phone call you you you discuss them in
one phone call and leave it at that
don't oversell yourself so what do I
mean by that if you haggle for a
significant increase on the initial
offer or you push from a man outside the
salary you will be setting an extremely
high expectation when you come on board
if you feel you can meet that
expectation then all fed use to you
however this is a particularly an
important point I think for those of you
who are looking to transition to a
different career you really need to be
mindful of this if a company ends up
paying you the salary for someone with
five years experience in that role and
you only have one year experience their
expectation is that you will operate at
the higher benchmark and you may find
yourself facing a very steep learning
curve the benchmark for achievement
bonuses and other key performance actors
may also end up being much higher than
you expected so moving on to our next
slide and topic I'm just going to
quickly because I know I want to give
you guys time for QA a few words about
negotiating pay rise during performance
reviews this is going to take on
slightly different connotation from when
you're negotiating at the initial offer
stage these are the points that I think
that might be helpful to you to bear in
mind so if you are coming up to a pay
performance review or you know just from
the way how your company operates when
that point in time is coming up for them
to start doing the reviews or the
management team are working on it
think about speaking to your manager
about it at that stage it's all about
timing you want to aim to discuss your
pay rise request before the salary
increases are agreed further up the
chain otherwise you will not need to be
told is too late for any additional
changes to the salaries to be made and
you don't want to sort of be trying to
haggle at a time when there is no way
that your boss will consider having to
go further up the chain and put your
request before other senior management
team members so it's better for you to
learn and understand at what point in
time do they start these discussions and
it's at that point in time you want to
be able to arrange a meeting with your
manager or supervisor and start the ball
rolling with discussions around your
what type of salary you would like and
your business case for why you feel that
the salary increase is justified or your
rationale again because they make sure
you've done your salary research you
should have a clear number in mind or a
tight salary range that you're looking
for when you raise your thick up of your
manager let them know that you've done
your research and reference your sources
okay
let them know don't be afraid to share
whichever salary calculation tool you've
use if you've seen information buy it
about your company in specific and what
they're offering share that source with
them yeah give them the full picture if
a colleague discloses their pay to you
Konica don't often do it but you know
some of us have close bond with
colleagues and it may end up coming in
coming up in the conversation do not use
it as a bargaining chip okay there could
be very
reasons why their salary differs from
yours so you don't want to bring that in
the conversation
keep it objective don't bring that type
of subjectivity into it also keep the
conversation separate so you may have
ten things that you want to discuss with
your manager when it comes to discussing
about your salary do not mix them into
the mix mids of conversation okay put my
hundred percent focus on this one thing
you want your managers a hundred percent
attention time and attention on this one
issue noting it do not give an ultimatum
so unless you have a job offer you are
genuinely considering accepting or you
are happy to work away walk away from
your job do not threaten to leave if
they don't increase your pay remember
even if you get what you want this per
Sarah your relationship with your boss
and you have to continue working with
them for the next foreseeable future
turning onto your next slide again just
finishing off negotiating pay rise
performance review what the lightly come
that might be so some of you may have
heard this in the past when you've asked
what if you don't get what you want
right so what if they sent we don't have
the budget for it this year
well rather than let the conversation
drop then ask them when you think you'll
have the budget keep that conversation
moving if your boss won't or can't
commit ask how close does he think will
she think you can come to my numbers
right alternatively if they think that
you haven't met a certain benchmark or
if they think that you need to move up a
certain level to in order to increase
your pay ask them how can I gain the
skills needed to get up to the next
level always be seeking to tie them into
a next point or a next time for review
or something else that you can go back
to them with ultimately sometimes things
just don't work out no matter how much
you push they may not be any movement
and you may find that this has been
happening year after year and ultimately
it may well be a signal then it's just
time for you to move on so just be open
and go with the flow but try and get
your manager to commit over to another
date when you can discuss it again or a
point in time that's helpful for both of
you to move things along okay
take away points quickly I'm going to go
through the takeaway points know your
financial worth and value you salary
tools to help you understand your
financial wealth and value from the
company's perspective don't be pressured
to giving a quick answer okay you'll
often find that an HR manager recruiter
loves nothing less than to keep you on
the phone and get you to commit what do
you think what do you think about those
figures don't give in to that pressure
remember your compensation package is
more than your salary negotiate your
benefits take the emotion out of the
conversation preparation is key prepare
your response and practice practice
practice if you need additional support
or help around the salary negotiation
book a session with a career coach to
further support you on how you structure
this or how you go about this and
sometimes things don't go our way it
could be time for you to move on so on
the next slide you'll see that there are
a couple of resources really from this
session that I wanted to share with you
in case you wanted to take her out away
so it's just some suggested reading
around salary negotiation for those of
you who may want something a bit more
in-depth and also I've got the links to
the a couple of the salary websites so
compare ibly I don't know how many of
you have used compatibly calm but it's
actually tailored to the tech industry
and shares salary ranges and it also
shares culture reviews so some of you
might find that one interesting to use
and that ladies and gentlemen brings us
to the end of our webinar so we've got a
couple of minutes left and I'm happy to
take some Q&A if you've got any
questions so if anybody's got any
questions that they'd like to monster
please shout them out mirror is there
anything that you can see in particular
that you think that you can shout out
let's have a look yeah people are asking
you can get to re-watch this - link yes
this webinar is being recorded and I
will share the link with you also yeah
you will get to record this I see Mira's
on stat Thank You mirror yes so we have
a couple of questions here is there a
way to find out the best financial offer
the company may be willing to give
without being considered greedy not
really I mean this is where you it's
almost a bit like a dance they're never
going to reveal what their range is and
this is why it really helps but if
you're able to find out specific
information on their company on that
particular company so like I mentioned
to you salary comm and I think I'm
probably does it as well has a company
review sites though you may find that
your company in particular or the one
that you're interviewing at is on that
site and I suggest going into the
company section and finding out as much
as you can about the salary range that
they offer and bearing in mind that will
also be tailored to how many years
experience somebody had so their
criteria for paying somebody at the
maximum and maybe based on their number
of factors it may be based also on what
unique skill set the person is bringing
to the role and also as I mentioned
before how critical is the role to the
business so if there are two people in
the team and there's only one person and
they're struggling to me business demand
they may well be willing to pay a lot
more for somebody to come on board then
if you're in a team will say 10 or 12
people so thanks for that Jackie we have
one more question from Michelle she's
asking in large investment banks who
knows when you negotiate your salary is
it HR and your immediate line manager or
many managers up in the line so your
immediate line managers should know they
should have there should be a timetable
so and I say this cuz I come from a
banking background as well and I know
that you know if experience for the
banks I've worked in is that there is so
much time and effort that goes into that
whole process that really if they are
going
to announce what the pay increases are
say in tune by say December at the end
of that year really they're starting to
kick off the process and your manager
will be asked about feeding in at the
pipeline to their thoughts about you you
should also have in your diary depending
on how you operate certain one two ones
which can gauge how you're performing
this is that the time when you need to
reflect whether or not you've met your
obligations or your goals so some
companies use smart for example and so
your goal
specific measurable all of that you need
to then be able to determine have you
hit that and at that point start to
think of if there isn't a one to one in
the calendar with your HR manager with
your your immediate manager then set one
up will ask to speak to them and go to
them and ask them specifically about
whether they've already started to feed
in on this whole process and mention to
them that you would like to set up a
conversation with them or a meeting with
them to discuss your salary so there are
a lot of questions which have come in
Jackie but the thing is that I guess the
time is up so we will have to choose
probably one more question and I will go
with Manish is asking how reliable are
these tools as they rely on data
reported by some employees or ex
employees which is not huge actual
figures may vary so is it okay to rely
on them to greater extent now that so
that's a great question actually because
some tools are better than others so for
example salary.com and you'll see on the
resources page which actually Mira has
that right now salary comm is a very
reliable tool because they collect
worldwide HR reported compensation data
so this information is coming in
directly from HR at these companies and
I think the ones that you may have to
watch out for more is like pay scale so
pay scale uses crowd-sourced data and so
what you really need to find out is what
is the source of data used to pull all
that information from is it coming from
actual individuals like cloth store does
as well or is it crowd-sourced data so
Jackie are you going to be on courier
hot line chat now Aimee
oh I moving over to the Korea hotline
chatroom now so for those of you who may
want to continue the conversation I'm
going to be in the track room again some
of these questions may be specific to
your personal circumstances
you may find it easier better to book
some time with one of the career coaches
obviously you've got myself a mirror on
the call and but there are other career
coaches that you may feel free to reach
out to book a session with us and we can
talk to you more and thoroughly through
your situation your questions on this
topic so I hope you all have enjoyed
this the recording will be available
soon and the presentation slide back
sorry I'm happy to share that with you
all if you're interested and I hope to
see some of you over in the student hub
shortly
okay thanks everybody take care enjoy
the rest of your day
you